du bonjour françois bayrou bon je vous
êtes bien là vous merci oui c'est le
générique est pas là vous êtes là où
causé l'essentiel haut commissaire au
plan maire de pau merci d'être là je ne
sais pas s'il y aura des manifestations
dans votre ville aujourd'hui en tout cas
il ya une grève à l'éducation nationale
il y aura sans doute des pancartes qui
évoqueront ibiza évidemment relativement
tôt vacances prises par jean michel
blanc car ce qui a provoqué vous le
savez une belle controverse est ce que
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
donné des bâtons pour se faire battre
dans cette affaire politique
[Musique]
d'abord je ne suis pas dans le secret ou
dans l'intimité
de jean michel blanquer remet ce qu'on a
compris en lisant les journaux c'est que
c'était quatre jours de voyage de noces
puisque c'était son mariage
donc bon qu'on puisse prendre quatre
jours entre noël et le premier de l'an
quand on a célébré ou fêter un événement
familial qui a son importance
ça paraît pas absurde après le savait
très bien ce n'est pas la question la
question de la concomitance entre ses
vacances à ibiza et la rentrée scolaire
le fait qu'il ait annoncé un proche des
cols très compliqué formé de facto très
compliqué depuis ce lieu de vacances et
ça le problème ceci est une deuxième
question
le fait que les décisions les règles et
normes soient prises tard
et soit prise tellement complexe que
beaucoup de gens n'arrivent pas à s'y
retrouver c'est ça la véritable question
est pourquoi pas ce qu'il y à 2
2 sortes de préoccupation première
préoccupation l'école deuxième
préoccupation le sanitaire qui est
dirigé par comme vous savez toutes les
instances qui enfants s'occupent de la
santé en tout cas l'idée qu'
on puisse se perdre dans la complexité
des choses il faut que tous les
responsables comprennent que c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles les gens se
détournent de
d l'action publique dé des grandes
orientations des décisions qui sont
prises c'est tellement compliqué
tellement bureaucratique tellement
bordée de tous les côtés ceinture et
bretelles comme on a l'habitude de dire
que les gens et vous et moi tout
aucun d'entre nous ne s'y retrouve
vraiment et ce et ce travail qui est un
travail de lisibilité
de des décisions qu'on prend ce travail
pour l'instant n'a pas été fait comme
les français l'attendent ray et donc
vous comprenez l'exaspération des
parents des profs je comprends manier
voir aujourd'hui il va travailler à pau
mais
je crois pas que ce soit par des
manifestations que ça que ça s'arrange
ça traduit un état d'esprit mais vous
voyez bien que le les questions qui se
posent à l'école sont des questions
beaucoup plus large et beaucoup plus
fondamentale pour la pour la société
bien sûr c'est un organisme que vous
connaissez bien pour l'avoir dirigé
pendant plusieurs années et il est
sensible et très sollicité depuis le
début de la crise en tout cas vous vous
dites il ya eu là un excès de zèle ou en
tout cas à défaut toute simplicité voilà
dans la décision qui a été prise et par
jean michel blanquer sans doute olivier
verront d'ailleurs en tout cas leurs
sanitaires on renvoie toujours ça sur
les ministres alors qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres organisations administratives
et et et normatives
que les ministres ne contrôle pas
toujours directement un mot de l'école
valérie pécresse a regretté mardi soir
la fermeture par jean michel blanquer
dans la réorganisation du bac de la
filière s dont elle a dit elle est sans
doute issue que c'est la filière des
bons élèves est ce que c'est une
une phrase que vous approuvez l'enfant
n'ont donc alors je vous dire deux
choses le bac valérie pécresse a défendu
c'est le bac que j'avais créé le bac s
es l et es
c'est une organisation que j'avais mise
en place communiste de l'éducation
deuxièmement pourquoi la vaige mise en
place pour une raison simple je voulais
que tous les dons soient également
respecté que tout les
que tous les talents toutes les et la
référence 2000 tu reçois également
respecter est meilleure et que
le on ne concentre pas dans une seule
filière
tous les entre guillemets bon élève
c'est une expression que sur laquelle je
suis pas très à l'aise parce que souvent
les bons élèves c'est les fils des
familles qui ont pu les aider ils sont
les matins et donc donc je ne voulais
pas qu'on concentre et on avait réussi à
créer trois voies de dignité égale je
suis c'est à djems vous voyez alors
germinal j'aime beaucoup les sciences
mais je suis un littéraire est ce qu'il
ya eu une formation il ya un dévoiement
puisque ces deux femmes et il ya eu des
dévoiements au travers du temps il ya
une chose qui manque me semble-t-il
c'est un tronc commun sur lequel on
puisse être assurée que au fond toute la
nation tous les jeunes de la nation ont
le minimum vital pour traverser la vie
et dans ce tronc commun il ya des
aspects d'expression la langue la
maîtrise de la langue la capacité de
dire ce qu'on a en soi savait très
souvent les violences des jeunes
viennent de ce qu'ils arrivent pas
exprimer ce qu'ils ont tant de haller ça
explose et donc la langue c'est très
important le ce qu'on appelle littéraire
c'est très important tous les cons
quence d'ailleurs qui ont beaucoup de
succès oui et que dans laquelle peut
à lui seul devant le pardon est ce que
ca droit de valorisé à ce point ceux qui
sont bons en maths c'était ça ma
question un peu basique pardon
voulait dire est ce que les maths sont
la voie de l'excellence oui ça ne peut
pas être la seule voie de l'excellence
croire que c'est une seule voix qui
donne l'excellence c'est se tromper et
donc ce que je préconise c'est un un
tronc commun dans lequel il ya le
minimum vital le viatique pour aller
dans la vie et puis ensuite des des voix
dans lesquelles chacun exprime ce qu'il
a de meilleur
et la concentration en une seule voix de
dit excellence ne va pas
alors autre chose mais ça préoccupe
évidemment en premier les français c'est
le pouvoir d'achat
que faire face à la nouvelle hausse
record de carburant faut-il que le
gouvernement envisage nouvelles mesures
d'urgence françois bayrou ce qu'il a
fait sur l'énergie en particulier sur
l'électricité en particulier et sans
aucun précédent oui mais ce qu'ils
aiment à ma question c'est est-ce que
non mais laissez moi le dire qu'ils
aient chèque énergie il ya eu le chèque
inflation non il ya beaucoup plus que ça
si on avait laissé jouer les mécanismes
prévus par toutes les règles et toutes
les noix l'électricité aurait augmenté
de 45%
44% et le gouvernement est intervenu
avec force et et en dépensant ou en
mettant sur la table beaucoup d'argent
pour que la hausse que réduite de 45%
soit une hausse de 4%
et celles pour ceux qui se chauffent
alex et tenez normes et former tout le
monde utilise l'électricité pourri pour
son ménage pour les machines à laver
pour
mes jetons par mois du prix à la pompe
le prix du carburant ils essaient
nouvelle nouveau record 1,68 en moyenne
le sans plomb 95
les français sont à nouveau frappés par
cette hausse est empêchée est-ce qu'il
faut une nouvelle un nouvel effort du
gouvernement en fait il a dépensé plus
de 10 milliards déjà oui ben vous voyez
bien eh ben ce qui vous qui avez vous
formulez pourquoi ça explose parce que
le prix des hydrocarbures dans le monde
a explosé oui et c'est probablement pas
fini
parce que comme vous savez le
à la fois la préoccupation de décarbonés
la vie de tous les jours et
les marchés du monde et les
interventions sur les marchés du monde
font que en effet ce prix-là augmente
donc je ne crois pas qu'on le fera
baisser beaucoup mais j'ai toujours
plaidé pour des mesures de régulation je
crois d'ailleurs que le ministre de
l'économie a dit que qui surveillait ça
au jour le jour dit je ne ferme pas la
porte dans la raison de sa fermé la
porte et la raison d'envisager une aide
c'est ma question je dis moi que ça va
se faire sous forme d' aide on peut
avoir des modulation des taxes on peut
avoir j'avais plaidé pour des mécanismes
de régulation au début dé gilet jaune ou
avant les gilets jaunes vous en
souviendrez peut-être et donc peut-être
on peut travailler sur ce sujet donc
vous êtes favorable à cette
à ce jeu sur les taxes qui est très
coûteux pour les caisses de l'état vous
voyez bien
tout le monde dit il faut intervenir
mais personne n'est capable de mettre
sur la table l'argent nécessaire pour la
raison que nous savons est mal à dire
qu'il y a à reconstruire des pans
entiers de l'économie française oui
c'est le travail que nous faisons au
commissariat au plan avec toutes les
idées de reconquête de la production
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse pour le coup
a dit y a pas de solution à court terme
elle a admis donc à la raison elle a eu
la candidate à l'elysée a eu raison
d'admettre
elle n'avait pas elle est contre la
politique du chéquier et là pas de
solutions à court terme excellent accès
d'honnêteté intellectuelle
si on veut non l'europe emmanuel macron
et ses adversaires politiques ont-ils
donné une bonne image de l'europe hier
au parlement de strasbourg en
travaillant 16 les adversaires du
président de la république ont de l'avis
unanime donner une mauvaise image de la
france pas de l'europe de la france en
europe et vous avez entendu sans doute
le nombre de députés européens y compris
est très très
sympathisants de la france très
francophile qui ont dit mais on peut pas
se comporter comme ça on est au début
d'une présidence c'est à dire au moment
où celui qui va avoir pendant six mois
le pays est le président qui va avoir
pendant six mois la responsabilité
de la conduite de l'union européenne
vient donner son programme et vous avez
entendu son discours il n'y a pas un mot
de politique française dans le discours
qui fait le discours c'est un discours
de 2 sur les grands bus de l'union
européenne sur ce qu'on veut en faire
sur comment va intervenants corps il a
pris le risque par dont il a pris le
risque de cumuler cette présidence le
visage de l'union européenne il aurait
pu ne pas le faire
et en même temps qu'il achève son mandat
donc ils s'exposent de fait à ce que ce
soit aussi instrumentalisé votre
affirmation n'a pas de sens je vous le
dis amicalement ça n'a pas de sens vous
n'imaginez pas que la france va dire
excusez moi c'est notre tour une fois
tous les 13 ans d'être à la tête des
institutions européenne de présider
l'union européenne mais on va pas le
faire parce qu'on a une élection pendant
ce moment qu'il trouvait que ça a un
sens de prendre une présidence de six
mois dont on ne sait pas ça va durer
finalement que trois mois la france
nettement excusez moi la france a des
responsabilités
internationales et des responsabilités
dans l'union européenne c'est pas tel ou
tel dirigeant qui a des responsabilités
c'est la france qui a des
responsabilités si on n'est pas un pays
capable de mettre un tout petit peu
entre parenthèses
nos querelles
internes médiocre parce que beaucoup des
accusations étaient meilleurs que c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est la présidente
du parlement européen qu'il dit est donc
franchement respecter l'europe
certains peuvent dire pro européen
convaincu respectez l'europe sort et
était effectivement de décaler cette
présidence pour qu'il n'y ait pas
regarder ce qui s'est passé hier
européen convaincu j'estime l'être
autant que qui que ce soit cette
ambiance à personne dans le champ
démocratique
je considère que nous avons des
institutions que ces institutions sont
faites pour être respectées
pas s'il en fait une faute hier ceux qui
ont utilisé cette tribune pas sans aucun
doute pour intégrer le près de hal en
france à l'ensemble des parlementaires
européens a ressenti cette attitude
comme une faute comme une mesquinerie
comme quelque chose de médiocre alors
qu'on débattait
de ce qui est à peu près essentiel c'est
à dire de la confrontation entre le
projet européen de sociétés de
civilisation de droits de l'homme de et
les pressions du monde et dans cette
affaire on se retrouve avec des
querelles et des mots qui franchement
n'était pas à l'auteur tout le monde l'a
ressenti et je trouve que le président
de la république c'en est très
élégamment tirer avec ce qu'il faut de
2,2 petite pointe d'acidité pour montrer
que ce n'était pas tout à fait passé
inaperçu et en même temps une maîtrise
des dossiers dont vous avez peut-être vu
que tous les parlementaires européens
lui ont rendu hommage vous auriez voter
pour le président du parlement roberto
mais de cela d'origine maltaise hostiles
à l'avortement
jeu c'est un accord entre groupes et je
n'ai jamais été partisan de ce type
d'accord entre groupes vous souviendrez
vous deviendrez voilà j'ai toujours
trouvé ça pas la hauteur vous
souviendrez peut-être que
parlementaires européens à l'époque
j'avais présenté la candidature de
geremek de prony slave guérini qui était
un de ceux qui avaient construit dans
son pays la pologne le le destin
européen
de cette europe + plus orientale est
tellement martyrisé
et puis ça a été battu par un médiocre
accords d'appareil là c'est un
accord d'appareils c'est c'est un accord
d'appareils et rien d'autre ouais et
donc et donc je trouve que c'est pas que
c'est pas formidable peut-être cette
jeune femme est sympathique je ne la
connais pas elle a l'air mais vous
regrettez quand même qu'elles sont soit
le produit de cela on rappelle que le
groupe renew
celui de des macros nist a effectivement
fait un accord
les accords majoritaires qui avait été
fait par les socialistes et le parti
populaire européen la droite européenne
est ce que le président de la république
française pour le coup doit attendre un
allègement des contraintes sanitaires
qui se profile peut-être
échéance d'une ou deux semaines pour se
déclarer candidat est ce que c'est un
critère jeunes ont le calendrier dont on
ne sait quoi critères alors tous les
présidents de la république sortant qui
se sont représentés ont annoncé leur
candidature
quelques semaines à peine avant le début
de la campagne électorale pour quoi
c'est très simple parce que dès
l'instant qu'ils annoncent leur
candidature il n'exerce plus tout à fait
leur présidence de la même façon parce
que dès cet instant là vous êtes sous la
pression d'attac encore plus virulentes
qu'elles ne l'étaient avant et dieu sait
qu'il y en a pas mal donc le plus tard
moyenne bien nous pour vous mange dis
pas ça non je ya il ya une zone 2 il ya
une zone de d'équilibré
qui se situe quelques semaines avant le
début de la campagne et qui est très
intéressant parce que pour moi
'l'annonce d'une candidature c'est pas
quelque chose de banal c'est le
basculement
dans un autre temps politique et ce tant
politique c'est
celui de de la vision de l'avenir quand
on est président on gère on
on essaie de d'assurer le présent de
faire face et on répond quand on est
candidat dans des perspectives cantonné
candidats en entonnant tout à fait autre
chose qui ait une vision de l'avenir
alors on redescend un peu si vous voulez
bien est ce que vous êtes radin françois
bayrou
parce que certains le disent je vois là
cette citation dans le parisien vous
avez lu hier matin signé d'un maquereau
nice l'anonyme le modem s'est dépeint ce
bon c'est une expression un radin on dit
que c'est une pince bayrou ces pics ou
pire c'est grippe sou
parce que parce qu'il paraît que vous
refusez de contribuer au financement de
la campagne
électorale des manuels macron je ne
participe à aucune médiocrité si je peux
c'est pas facile parce que c'est un
moment dans lequel
l'abondance est plutôt du côté de la
médiocrité que du côté de la générosité
ou d'une certaine hauteur de vue que je
ne participe à aucune médiocrité mais
c'est vrai que je n'aime pas le
gaspillage de l'argent aux politiques
financiers lendemain je suis à la tête
du seul parti politique je crois
français qui n'a pas de dette
qui a constitué un patrimoine au travers
du temps et ce patrimoine assure sa
liberté et je ne suis pas pour les
campagnes électorales cher je n'aime pas
et donc est donc qu est ce qu est ce que
vous avez dit alarm qui vous réclame
d'abord d'un blanc personne ne m'a
réclamé quoi que ce soit et je dis
simplement ne dépensons pas trop ça ne
sert à rien c'est de l'argent gaspillé
et dans ce et dans ses dépenses
raisonner naturellement nous prendrons
toute notre part de responsabilité mais
vous voyez bien que le genre de papier
que vous citez est pas tout à fait me
semble t'il à la hauteur des vagues oui
ça vous a déplu
on s'en fiche le sauna et ça nous a vus
et edouard philippe bonneau si vous avez
vu vous avez fait des tonnes et des
tonnes de papier d'éditoriaux sur
edouard philips envahie quitte la maison
commune ils disent on a il a annoncé
hier en tout cas son mouvement politique
en constitution annoncé hier que pas du
tout lui donc la bondrée toute simple la
brouille est terminée
badri je vais essayer de vous le dire à
ma manière à la rendre les secondes ma
manière de seconde c'est on a un devoir
c'est l'unité un seul devoir le champ
politique est explosée enfin c'est aussi
du rapport de force vous savez très bien
mais paul est bien nous en fait depuis
40 ans donc vous le savez trouve oui
vous du journalisme et il se trouve que
le que voilà et il se trouve que le que
le rapport de force va rien comme c'est
mieux il se trouve que je suis pas
sensible au rapport de force ou plus
exactement je sais que dans le rapport
de force quand vous êtes obstiné à
défendre quelque chose vous êtes plus
forts que ceux qui virevolte au vent et
donc je je ben ma ligne politique et
d'être
absolument obstiné dans des règles
simples je défend le pluralisme et je
défend l'unité et si on était plus
nombreux dans la vie politique française
je me donne pas l'exemple de ces jardins
ample mais si si on était plus nombreux
à défendre le pluralisme mrc lance un
bayrou que sa gueule merci françois
bayrou d'avoir été ce matin sur lci